dr wallach what about arthritis well
arthritis is my favorite disease because
it's easy to fix
it's one of the great myths that the
medical profession perpetuates is that
you can't build bone mass after the age
of 50 60 70 years of age you can only
slow down the loss
and the reason why they say that
is because they try to rebuild bone mass
using plain calcium whether it's tums or
calcium citrate or carbonate or
gluconator or lactate and your body will
not retain much or any of the calcium
you supplement with in your bones
without first building new bone matrix
you have to have new bone matrix this is
this this rubbery collagen material that
looks like tendon or skin and it makes
up 25 to 40 percent of our bone weight
40 when you're a child and 25 percent
when you're an adult and so it's
absolutely essential if you want to deal
with the wear and tear arthritis
osteoarthritis degenerative arthritis
ankylosing spondylitis effectively you
have to take all 90 essential nutrients
and the best way to do that is with dr
wallick's pig arthritis formula remember
i'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician and we learned a long time ago
maybe a hundred years ago in veterinary
medicine that we could actually prevent
and reverse maybe even use the cure word
and animals
arthritis simply by giving the animal
the raw material to
develop properly and to maintain and
repair the joints and so using this
information that we
developed in animals if you use the same
concept for human beings i have
literally seen tens of thousands of
people over the years who
had bone bone arthritis
they had osteoarthritis they have
degenerative arthritis ankylosing
spondylitis which are basically
a
joint form of osteoporosis it's
osteoporosis the joint ends of the bones
and they've tried all kinds of
medication and of course if you take
medication if you take a painkiller if
you take an anti-inflammatory for
arthritis essentially all you're doing
is cutting the wire the red warning
light pain in a joint says don't use me
until you fix me and by taking a
painkiller by taking a anti-inflammatory
which will reduce pain
you're allowing that joint to be used
even though it would have been painful
without the drug and so you're wearing
that joint out faster and faster and
faster and to me it's criminally
negligent for someone to be prescribed a
painkiller or an anti-inflammatory for
joint disease without repairing the
joint at the same time and this is where
the arthritis formula really shines and
works just like a charm in human beings
you